hi
everybody i'm maury samuels the director
of the yale program for the study of
anti-semitism
and i'm very happy to welcome you here
uh today
to the final benjamin and barbara zucker
lecture
of the academic year today's speaker
james or jake mccauley is a bit of a
wonder count he earned his ba from
harvard
and his d fill in history from oxford
where he was a marshall scholar
in his 30 short years he's already been
the paris correspondent for the
washington post and is now
a global opinions contributing columnist
there he
i'm happy to say also that he's been
invited next year to be
a frankie fellow at the whitney
humanities center
at yale his new book the house of
fragile things
about jewish art collectors in fantasy
eclipse france and the anti-semitism
they faced
which he's going to be talking about
today was just published by
yale university press and it's gotten
rave
reviews the wall street journal called
it alluring and disturbing
which i think is a pretty good
description of the complex
world that the book describes and the
ambivalent emotions that the book evokes
i just finished the book and i have to
say that it manages really
brilliantly to be both scholarly and
extremely readable uh it's a great read
so here is how things are going to work
today uh
jake will speak for about 30 minutes
then my colleague alice kaplan
sterling professor of french and the
director of the whitney humanities
center
will kick off the discussion and i will
ask
jake questions that you submit using the
q a
feature at the bottom of your screen
feel free to submit questions at any
point during the talk
but please don't raise your hand because
we can't see you
so now without further ado i will hand
it over to jake who i think has some
slides also to show
that's right um thank you so much maury
for that very kind introduction
and it is terrific to be here with you
and alice today
um both both of you helped me so much
in more ways that i can that i can say
here with the book
as i was hustling to finish it over this
past year of lockdowns
and um and so on so it's um
it's a pleasure to be here with you
today and thank you so much for having
me
and for all the kind words um about the
book
um which i'm happy to talk a little bit
about with all of you
today so as maurice said the book
is called the house of fragile things um
it is a study of a beleaguered
jewish elite on the brink of catastrophe
so kind of following a network of five
intermarried families between um
the fender sector kind of with dreyfus
the the dreyfus affair i should say
and the arrival of uh the second world
war in 1940
and um so in that time there was of
course the first world war
but also various uh strains of
anti-semitism that
targeted these families in public and
always by name and that sort of hounded
them and that
they could never really escape um given
that they were as i mentioned this sort
of elite that was
the um that that basically was they they
were the custodians of the french jewish
experience at that time and by that i
mean
they were the heads of the communal
organization such as the consistent
and the the alliances
and they were you know they were
uh members of the french parliament like
the reinock family was the big defenders
of dreyfus during the affair
also the rhinox they were um
governors and philanthropists that
supported cultural life
all across france such as um the
rothschilds and alphonse de rothschild
in particular
and so they are at the heart of this
um very uh particular experience
in a fraught moment and so i mean the
complicated thing
is that both the um
uh you know the the period of the
dreyfus affair
and the second world war and then also
just the sort of jewish experience in
france in general
are such well-trodden territories in
scholarship as all of us know and of
course
you know i'm here today with with mori
and alice both of whom have written so
much and so well about all of that that
you know
when i was looking at all this stuff you
know i i struggled to
to ask my to to answer you know the
question of what was
what what is left to say and what is
sort of um a contribution
um to be made in um the research i was
doing
and i think you know after um
after after reading everything i could
and after um
kind of brainstorming about what to what
to say about this
um this community it occurred to me that
pretty much every single one of these
great um
these great families had bequeathed a
collection of art or a
um family home intended to be a sort of
private museum
to the french state in the 1920s and 30s
so before
the before the war before the holocaust
before the ending that we all know
and these donations really seem to me
uh very interesting because on the one
hand
they they um they offer sort of multiple
avenues of interpretation
on the one hand um as you know
as collections they are um
expression and then here i'm indebted to
the to the phrase of the art historian
annie gonna they're self-portraits of
the collectors themselves right in
collections there's an enormous
literature about this
collections exist at the intersection of
the psychological and the social
there is you know there's what a
collector chooses to collect
corresponds to some sort of subjective
aspect of his or her person
whether it's you know a childhood memory
whether it's a sense of aspiration
whether it's some kind of um kind of
strange
uh um kind of personal desire or
um to use the phrase that i love from
susan stewart's study of collecting it's
a sense of longing
um and so there's all of that sort of
hyper personal hyper individualistic
uh component um components to collecting
but then also
given that this is a network of
interconnected
uh families um and and collectors who
have a very similar background
in the same moment um there is also the
social aspect and so
what collectors choose to collect in a
given moment in time is often a function
of
what is in style in that particular time
and
what the style is in a given moment is
also
very interesting so you know for example
in the victorian era there was the
revival of the gothic um in fantasy
france the sort of um uh very in vogue
style
was the ancient regime
popularized by the likes of julen and
mong gong
and others and i'll i'll talk a little
bit more about that in a minute when i
have my um
my slides up and running but i thought i
would just sort of briefly introduce the
the sort of general arc of the book
before we go any further so
i was always really interested in these
collections and what they tell us
and again there's no simple answer
because we're talking about
um very complicated nuanced individuals
who have any number of different
perspectives and opinions
on the moment that they're living in but
as a group and and i should say also
that each of the families that i
consider
are um intermarried and um
related through various channels and so
you know to borrow high-end berman's
famous phrase from the 70s it's really a
cousinhood i mean
they're really all a big family in a
sense and so
they all knew each other they were all
thinking
uh fairly similarly about um their
legacies
and this for so many of them was was
um their legacy and and so i think that
that
is um is quite rich for interpretation
and you know i should say that um
you know it's interesting because you
know the characters in the book um
they are all from jewish families but
they have a very you know diverse
array of relationships to judaism and
jewishness you know some
are very invested in religious
observance
some are communal leaders as i mentioned
um
the rothschilds were at one point the
head of the constitution theodore
reinoke who is a big character in the
book and one of my favorites
was um you know a great sort of theorist
of um uh franco judaism following in the
footsteps of the likes of
the halle vs a generation before and you
know he founded
the precursor to the synagogue that
still exists in paris today the liberal
synagogue on the route
uh for those of you um who who may be
familiar with that
and so um there's that side but then
there are others who had
no sense of jewish identity at the end
at all and who had converted
who had married uh non-jews who had who
had you know kind of distanced
themselves from the
the um tradition of their forefathers
and it's interesting that at the end of
the day of course you know the the
nature of their identities is not up to
them to arbitrate
um during the second world war with nazi
occupation and the holocaust
but um you know so it it is a sort of um
uh i realize that on some level it's a
strange grouping but
i do think that um for so many of them
going through the same um lived
experience and the same
uh very fraught complicated moment the
collections really are
a profound statement when taken together
and i'll show you a little bit more
about what i mean by that in a minute
but just um um you know in general what
i try to do here
with this book is essentially to look at
these collections as expressions of a
um a kind of
evolving uh french jewish identity
um and you know here i think a lot about
mori's work about uh on the israelites
um you know he mori has considered this
in the terms of fiction
as a laboratory for the construction of
that very
french very 19th century jewish identity
and i try to do the same
through the um realm of material culture
and art and objects
um and and i i hope we can talk a little
bit more about that too as we as we go
along
you know and finally if if the book has
an argument i would say
it's essentially three things
um you know on the one hand it
it's that the anti-semitism and you know
i should say also i'm not the first to
to go here there's there's um there's
been a lot of excellent scholarship
on this front um from the likes of tom
stammers at durham university and
others but that the anti-semitism of the
fanduesjack
was at least to a certain extent
largely aesthetic or material in nature
and by that i mean
it was a um a hatred of jews
expressed through the language of of art
and objects and things
and that's very important and then the
second part of that argument
is that for many of these very um
established
um uh important french jewish families
in this
time their response was
also rendered in the language of objects
and things and that is sort of how i see
these collections
as rejoinders to the sort of hateful
invective they could never escape
and finally i i really do believe
that these collections are to some
extent
um uh portraits
of individual sensibilities but also
um uh expressions of a
of a durable french jewish identity that
was that was not mutually exclusive and
that was very compatible and that
presented frenchness and jewishness
perhaps even as symbiotic extensions of
each other
in again an extremely fraught moment in
which anti-semitism was rampant
and there was no escape um you know i
think um
very much often of the the line toward
the beginning of
of um proust's in search of lost time
when marcel
um invites a jewish friend over to play
after school one day or something like
that
and his grandfather hums certain tunes i
believe even from
the halle the opera lajriv versus or
something else that could be mistaken
but the point is uh when the the
small jewish boy comes over to his house
the grandfather hums these tunes that
sort of mark his difference
and the point of the book in a way is
that all of these collectors live their
lives to the sound of that music to some
extent
and um it was something that they tried
to overcome
and that i i you know i really think
that
the art and the objects that they
collected as donations to the state
were meant to put an end to that once
and for all and to demonstrate
a not only a jewish fidelity to the
french republic but
um uh a sort of um
profound sense of belonging and and and
also of contribution
to french cultural patrimony so with
that said
um i will now show some slides and sort
of
walk you through a little bit of what's
in the book um
so let me just do that real quick all
right and just to be sure can we
we can see all of this okay
okay um all right
so i mentioned as well um a minute ago
the the style that was in vogue that
many of these collectors
uh prioritized and that was the style of
the unseen regime
now of course um the late 19th century
you know had
any number of different sort of artistic
movements but
there was a certain rediscovery of the
pre-revolutionary
kind of the the fete gallon the halcyon
days
before the french revolution of you know
aristocrats and leafy glades
and um kind of carefree uh nonchalance
uh
the whimsy of you know people like vato
and
uh fragrance
and what you're looking at right here is
um
a room from the musee uh nissim de
kamondo
and the kamlando family was well is
the sort of crux of the book and you
know an excellent example of one of
these
um jewish families that embraced this
particular period with a fervent passion
so the
the camel does arrive from france i'm
sorry in france from constantinople in
the 1860s before 1870
and um they are a wealthy banking family
they're referred to as the rothschilds
of the east
and they essentially begin to get into
the realm of
um of art as they get wealthier
and seek to you know establish
themselves on the parisian social scene
and this is the collection of luis de
camundo who's one of the main characters
in my book
and you know moise was truly obsessive
in the way that many collectors become i
mean he
is it was essentially his full-time job
at the end of his life all he did
was sort of peruse things that his
dealers would send him or suggest to him
and say
no most of all and sometimes yes and
to get him to say yes it had to adhere
exactly to his sort of temporal vision
because what he was doing is essentially
trying to recreate the puertitriano
um the kind of uh guest house
that was marie antoinette's playground
at versailles
um on the rudim also in his family house
so it was about
um recreating the sense of royal
providence and just on that
the royal providence is key in the the
late 19th century for so many of these
families and
other collectors i should say non-jewish
as well
um the revival of this sort of
um formally noble style in that time
was a means of aspiration
and projection right so the late 19th
century
you have the emergence of this um you
know what in france we call the old bunk
the big bank era and that created a
whole class
and there were also wealthy
industrialists and you know whole new
fortunes being made all the time and
that created
a a class of consumers that desperately
wanted the trappings of bourgeois life
to project
an image of cultural refinement and
sophistication that they may not have
been able to show otherwise
and so there is a kind of aspiration
about this style
um this is maui's de kamondo by the way
um and another example this is um
the chateau de champs of man outside of
paris and this
is the um this is another kind of uh
important family in the book the key and
they are
the family that co-founded the bank
known as today paribas
although it's gone through several
transformations since they created it
with the bishops time the bishop symes
in the late 19th century um this is
another kind of um this chateau was
restored
by the kandong vera family they bought
it in 1895 and restored it with desta yo
the architect and essentially um
you know what i think was going on here
and i don't know for sure but what i
think
based on what i have found in the
archives namely
a kind of historical pamphlet written
about the site by one of the canned on
their children
was a way of writing jews into
french history which is a very important
motive as well with this
sort of um collecting and home design
relying on um urban objects with
particular provenances like that's very
important so
the chateau is an 18th century uh
kind of bijou gem that you know
was revered by many it had played host
to voltaire
chateaubriand in its day and so you know
it has this story of history right
and so the canned on theirs buy it
restore it and then
seek to establish themselves in that
kind of lingerie historical narrative as
natural
and perhaps even inevitable participants
in it
and i think that that's a another really
important um element of what's going on
here with this
particular style in this jewish elite
and here is um here are portraits of mr
and mrs k
and don louis and louise
um for those of you who have read the
hair with amber eyes the
amazing book by edmond deval about 10
years ago louise candelve
who you can see here is a big figure in
that because you know she's a kind of
um leading socialite of the time and she
has an affair with charles eppercy
who is another kind of big um jewish
athlete
in this milieu
um just to give a sense i mean i have a
lot in the book about portraits and
about the way specifically women are
kind of objectified and treated as art
objects
um by their families specifically the
men and their families this is
one of several renoir portraits that
renoir did of the candle of their family
these are alice and elizabeth
camdenville and elizabeth candela who
you see
in the blue dress right there um she
ultimately is
um deported and murdered in auschwitz in
1944
when she's um in her mid 60s and very
ill so it's a terrible end to the story
um another um example in many ways my
favorite character in the whole book
is theodore rynock who was an amazing
academician
he was a parliamentary deputy a scholar
of antiquity
and also an impassioned collector so
what you have um next to him is the
villa carilos which is a painstaking
recreation
of a second century greek villa at delos
and um that was his that was his passion
i mean so the rhinox were
lead defenders of dreyfus they were
sort of um everywhere in fantasy
france i mean i'm always surprised that
you know they had the stature of
essentially the james family in the u.s
i mean they were like the william henry
and alice james
of third republic france and yet very
little of them remains today even
i mean if anything they just are
footnotes and stories about other people
but at the time i mean they were
hugely important and i i you know one
thing i hope comes about from the book
is that maybe they get a little bit more
um attention that they deserve um but
anyway so theodore reinoke
builds this house as a kind of refuge in
the time of the dreyfus affair
and it is meant to sort of achieve a
i would say a kind of greek ideal of
beauty i mean that's my interpretation i
don't know how convincing
those of you who will read the book will
find that but it is it is my view
i think that um you know rynock
is a guy who as i mentioned before was a
great sort of theorist of french judaism
and he he essentially
seeks to show that frenchness was
or is the jew that um
the jewishness was a sort of frenchness
of of antiquity if that makes any sense
that that jewishness has this
this kind of univ like universal
republican aim to it and that's his
way of i think showing um
french jewish compatibility in this like
deeply fraught
hostile moment that he lived in when for
instance
the french military wrongly accuses a
jewish military captain of treason
um and there are you know any number of
other anti-semitic scandals that erupt
so it's it's interesting because you
know the rhinox were proud jews always
and proud french republicans and
they seem to say or to suggest that
the particular is prior to the universal
um meaning the sort of the universal
citizenship ideal
in france but that the universal can
still be the aspiration of the
particular community and i think that
that's a very important
um interpretation that they made and
it's it's one that resonates
i think a lot in france today where of
course as we all know
citizenship and identity remain
categories
and religion of course um so hotly
contested and the boundaries of all of
that too
so um i find the run acts absolutely
fascinating for that reason
now just a little bit about the
particular nature of anti-semitism
in the time um i mentioned
that um there was this sort of invective
based on objects and things and you're
looking right here at a picture of
edward
who uh needs no introduction but just in
a sentence
he was one of the most virulent
anti-semites
in european history before the holocaust
and he was i mean it's often forgotten
and i mean here i draw on the remarkable
biography of drew mold by gregoire
kaufman
and also um some of the early works of
uh phil nord at princeton
but it's um it's often forgotten that
drummond was an antiquarian when he
started out
so he has this this real nostalgia to
him that's
i think so important for understanding
his hatred of jews so
he lives um longing for a paris that was
a simpler paris that was the sort of old
cobblestone streets before
the industrial transformation of the
city in the 19th century
before the railroads before the
department stores
um many of which were owned and operated
by
by jews of course and so he he makes
that association between
the kind of ruination of the paris of
his dreams which of course never existed
and um what he the you know the problems
he sees in his time
as being the faults of jews but what's
important to keep in mind there
is that it's a sort of material affront
that jews are responsible first and
foremost for this material desecration
of his ideal city and i
um you know unfortunately i had to read
so much of his um
uh infamous screed the reeve
which came out in 18 at the end of the
19th century
and basically made a fortune for the
publishing house
and you know in each of the chapters
there's a mention of one of these
families
and their collection but the collection
in his mind is one of their greatest
offenses because
they're buying objects that have this
french history and french provenance
that they have no business owning in his
in his eyes
and that they're living in these houses
again like the candles
at uh champs or marin that
um have that are not to be owned by jews
because jews are somehow always
um outside the national narrative and
you know for drummle
and also for the goku jews were somewhat
memetic
uh figures you know they were facsimiles
of frenchmen
they could never create admire
or appreciate true aesthetic beauty
and everything they created was airsats
and fake and the goncore
diaries have tons of these sort of
vindictive little vignettes
of dinner parties they attended at the
homes of these collectors in my book
and drummond as well so um i try to
argue you know we
everyone knows that drummond was a big
anti-semite but i think it's really
important
to understand the lived experiences of
these characters in the book these
actual jewish families
what it was like and the rhetoric that
they often encountered was an attack
on their um their their material
possessions and that
is i think a really really important
piece of the puzzle to keep in mind
um and just briefly one um story to that
end
what you're looking at here is the tiara
of saita farnes or the so-called tiara
of saito farnes
and this is one of the most tragic
stories in the book i think
um because it's it's a forgery
right so drew drumell had been arguing
for years that jews could not know
and detect and admire true beauty and
then here
was this forgery that was presented to
the louvre museum
um in the late 19th century um
by a kind of swindler guy from
uh odessa um and the guy who made it was
was jewish as was the swindler
and then the reinock family at the time
was on the museum advisory board and in
charge of the constitution
which basically oversaw the um
acquisitions and
new pieces purchased for collection and
they bought this and the rhinox avowedly
defended it they really believed that it
was
um a true gold tiara from saita farnes
um in the early i think it's the early
bce period although
i forget off the top of my head um and
there were doubts raised by many but
they sort of pushed it forward because
they really
they thought it would be a major coup
for the louvre museum and also for them
but then it turned out to be a disaster
this was shown to it was exposed to be a
fake
and the carefully cultivated sensibility
that the family projected
had a major major blow and for drew mall
it was a
major vindication and you can see here
there were these postcards um
uh basically you know with with
obviously um anti-semitic caricatures
and the tiara and front halls is a this
is a painting this is a kind of inside
baseball thing but this is a painting
that
um joseph rynock purchased at auction
not too
long before the tiara entered the louvre
so it was for the anti-semites of the
day
it was vindication and for the rhinox it
was utter humiliation
and you know i realized that there's a
lot of characters and a lot of people in
this but
i i tell this story just to give a sense
of
how high the stakes were for these
objects that
in theory seem like kind of bon bons or
sort of little ornaments to put it
put aside in the house but it was really
a matter of um
a reputation for so many of these people
and sometimes it went wrong
now just to conclude to tell you
all a little bit more about sort of what
happens to this millio this is a picture
of
nissim de kamondo and beatrice de
camundo
like many um uh french jews and this is
a well-trodden territory you know
philippe landau
derek pensler many have written about um
uh the jews of france serving in the
first world war
and how it was in a sense to use phillie
blando's phrase the apogee of the
israelites
um the the the moment at which jews felt
most proudly
at home in the french republic and he
seemed to camel there was one of those
so he
enlists in the military was drafted in
the military um
and ultimately dies in uh september 1917
fighting for france he dies behind enemy
lines in lorraine
in east france and that's what his
sister bear trista camundo
um who later during the second world war
is
arrested with her ex-husband and two
children and
deported to auschwitz where they are all
murdered and they of course they go to
draw see
the internment camp outside paris first
but
in a way the story of the kamundo is a
microcosm
of the jewish experience in modern
france
um at least before the second world war
you have the immigrant father
who um you know becomes super french in
his estimation
and who does everything he can and he
collects
passionately these um unseen regime
objects that i showed you
he leaves everything to the state his
son dies fighting for france
and then a generation later his daughter
is murdered by the same country that
his son died fighting for and um that he
left all of his worldly goods too so
it's a very tragic end to the story but
it just in a way it's the
it's the most sort of illustrative
example that i have in the story i think
um this is a picture of louise decamondo
and his son nisim
um this is a picture of the musee
camardo
when it opened in 1936 and you know
moise was obsessive about how everything
had to be run you know down to the
umbrella stands down to the dust um
how it was to be cleaned i mean he was
he really was
um a control freak as of course many
collectors are i mean he wouldn't
he refused to part with with basically
anything from his collection because you
know
after what he had been through having
lost his son
and his wife um it
you get the sense that the objects were
essentially
all that was solid in the life that had
otherwise
melted into air to use the famous phrase
of karl marx that you know the objects
gave
a certain fixity and stability and
structure to an otherwise
cruel outside world and um there's
something very
very sad about that i think um this is
the um the room in the camel door house
that kind of preserved the faces of the
family
that is a portrait of louise's father um
and you can't see it but there's a
little uh on the little kind of credenza
there's a portrait of his son a
photograph and then a statue of his
daughter
and that's what you see when you visit
the museum today the family was always
meant to be part of it and they
they they are and so it's on the one
hand this this weird
um kind of site of memory so to speak
because on the one hand you know if you
are an art student it's a great
collection of 18th century art one of
the finest
that you can find but then also it's um
it's the story of a family and
specifically of a jewish family
um in a very fraught moment and you have
all of that working at the same time
uh finally uh to that point about um
the different levels of memory you have
here
um the initial this is in the portica
share of the kamundo museum
it's you know you can see that the
museum was left in the honor of misumdu
kamundo
and then um it has a small plaque that
was added sometime in the
the 80s about what had happened to
beatrice uh the kamundo
in in auschwitz and then uh
finally you know this is not amelia
whose memory has fared very well
um i i had this photo from when i was a
phd student
and this is in central manola that kind
of fancy
suburb to the west of paris where the
rhinox really were based
and this um was outside i mean it was
then a faded
kind of um plaque that had seen better
days
to say the least and um that's sort of
all that remains of the family in public
um in france and then um it was taken
down and in the process of um
kind of doing some final fact checking
for the book um
i spoke with um uh uh i guess uh
uh official in the mayor's office at
incentivementalway just to ask for what
the deal with all that was
and was told that the plaque for the
rhinox which was peeling anyway was
taken down
i think 2015 for a renovation and then
they have no
plans to put it back up and again that
is for a family that was at the heart of
cultural and intellectual life in the
third republic and it's just
in a way a microcosm for the entire
um emilio that i try to evoke in the
book
and this is finally a photograph that i
love of beatrice de kamondo in profile
um taken not too long before she was
arrested
and and murdered and i think that the um
the the production of the photo kind of
gets at the
mystery of of what had happened to her
and in a way
if there's one person in the book that
um it's
for it really is her and i i tried to
the best of my ability to
find every trace that i could um of her
of letters that she had written and and
records of her
and i i found only a few but um i i i
don't know it's just a it's a
devastating story and i i
i wish that um uh more people would um
with more kind of researchers would look
into it because it's just it's really an
awful story
so with that um i will
uh i guess we can do the question part
now i feel like i'm rambling but um i
appreciate the chance to talk about the
book
and um right so i will stop the
powerpoint right there
thank you jake it's it's just gripping
to hear about
your book i this time as i was listening
i thought that
it draws us in because it's a reverse
fairy tale
you know it starts out with all the
glory and the fantasy in this glittering
world and then it
it ends you know in horror so
i am very moved to hear about beatrice
here's a question i do think that that
what you say about material
anti-semitism
is important and i have a few follow-up
questions
one is you know does it only concern the
rich
and then the second question is is it
just
for the french this material
anti-semitism so for example you have
wagner saying that jews couldn't produce
real art is material anti-semitism
of french product or general european
yeah i think that is an excellent
question and i
agree that it is not just a sort of
french phenomenon
i think that um in um
you know those sort of uh how to put it
in that sort of
aesthetic conversation there was always
or maybe not always but there was often
an attempt
to um well yet
as i was saying to sort of depict the
jew
as the inverse to authentic
uh beauty to somehow say
that the jew is a memetic figure merely
kind of performing an identity that he
or she can never actually
achieve or understand i do think that um
in i mean i think what i try to do in
the book
is to say that um while it may not be
distinctly french
this phenomenon it is really important
in
trying to understand the nature
of daily life for these these people
in the fantasy and you know i think
in so many uh you know often you know
when we use the
the the term anti-semitism it um
it actually means very different things
at different moments right so
in the enlightenment it was often a
hostility to judaism
as a religion that some saw as sort of
um backward in the age of
kind of rationality so to speak you know
it means
um uh like and then there was the era of
the the socialists who attacked jews for
perceived capitalistic tendencies and
then the list goes on and on
with the different sort of meanings at
different times and what i was trying to
show
is that in the fantasies um
there was a very important sort of
material nature to the critique that
these families were facing now
to your other point uh or your other
question i do think that this was
predominantly something that these
wealthy wealthier kind of um
more prominent families faced as opposed
to
um there are kind of lesser um
established counterparts you can't be a
peddler
you can't be accused to be the victim of
material anti-semitism if you're a
peddler
right exactly i mean i think there you
absolutely were accused of being a fake
frenchman for sure
but um you were not being attacked for
the objects that you
um owned or the homes that you you had
um although go ahead it's so interesting
because
i had always seen in tag ef and people
like that that distinction between the
blood and the racial anti-semitism which
i associate with germany
and the cultural anti-semitism and the
story you tell makes the cultural
anti-semitism sound
worse in some ways than the blood
anti-semitism yeah i mean i'm not sure
it's it's worse it it just
i don't know to me it's that that
there's no escape it's that
you know if you follow all of the rules
so to speak
there's just nothing you can do at the
end of the day
um even if you you
truly i mean i mean the other thing i
mean the goncur were
i should i should say they were the ones
who presided over the
revival of this sort of australian
regime style in the fandustjack right so
they're the ones that make it
that that sort of um lead to the
that preside over the rediscovery what
they call the delicious decadence and
you know
they're all about that and then you know
if you were a family like the kean del
ver who did exactly what they said and
bought all of the pieces that they
identified as
valuable or that that were somehow worth
having it wasn't good enough i mean
nothing
it was just uh it was all for nothing
which is sort of heartbreaking in a way
let me ask you one more question then
i'll turn it over to mori for the
audience questions you know i've been
thinking a lot about
algeria and the idea of apology or
restitution or something
and the idea that confessing a crime
doesn't let the criminal off the hook
so it seems that there's been more
acknowledgement recently about what
happened to these families
but is there going to be something else
i mean is there going to be an
acknowledgement an apology uh more
plaques the plaque put up is there any
activism around these stories
um to my knowledge there is no activism
i mean i think
as you mentioned you know there was some
a lot
of movement in the 80s and 90s and it
culminates with sharok's
big speech at the beldee um
kind of formally apologizing for francis
complicity in the holocaust
um and then there has been a very
commendable
although of course is never enough but a
commendable effort like the matteo
league commission to identify
stolen paintings and french museums and
to give them back
but you know aside from that from the
kind of restitution
claims um which are by the way only
available for paintings that we can
identify that we know the whereabouts of
i don't i mean i don't see any other
activism so it's just
you know the the state has done at least
in its own mind you know what it can do
and then the rest is just what it is and
it's sort of um
it's there's just a there's a huge
absence there
and that um is the worst part of all of
this
yeah you know there's a piece of your
book that makes
anyone ask if it could happen today
because some elite group yeah i mean
just to say it couldn't yeah okay
take it away maury all right well yeah
thank you for that that was just a
really um great summary of the book and
um i encourage
everybody to um ask questions using the
q a function
there's one to get us started from our
colleague um katie trumpner
who asks what um became
of the of the kamundo museum during
world war ii
during the german occupation um and then
if
i could just follow that up with the
question i had which is
um you end the book like one of the last
i think it's the last chapter before the
conclusion
is that what happens to the fate of that
port of the
the renoir portrait of um
uh the uh cayenne dover
girl so if you could just tell that
story sure yeah so so briefly i mean the
kamundo
um museum like a lot of these other
museums you know they they
it was donated to the state on the death
of louise de camonto in 1935.
it opens as a museum in 1936 um
it uh closes during the war but
the collection remains more or less
intact because
it was state property at the time and so
it's not necessarily the story of i mean
the the
i mean oddly the the book that i have
written is not really a book about
exfoliation because
a lot of the stuff in it the stuff
meaning the objects and the art that was
donated
had already been in um kind of french
state collections at the time of the war
now of course
there were some pieces that were stolen
um
but they were looted as um pieces that
belonged to the french government not
necessarily
to as pieces that belong to jewish
families um
now that said um
many of these families had private
collections on top of what was already
given to the state
and in those instances there was a lot
of
um nazi theft and um kind of horrible
stories
the likes of which you have seen in
movies like the woman in gold etc
and maury brings up um the
the famous portrait of irene candelfer
which actually i should have put in the
slideshow but naturally did not but it's
the famous portrait where
the young woman is in profile with kind
of red uh hair it's very beautiful
um that belonged to beatrice dicamondo
because it is a portrait of her mother
eren candelvere
and her husband who was the again i
apologize for all the names and for the
fact that
many of the names are the same but
anyway um it belonged to beatrice
decamondo and her husband leon reinoke
this portrait
and it had been given to the louvre
museum for safekeeping
uh before the war as did many collectors
it ends up in the chateau de chambord
with many louvre items
and then it's there that the er
the nazi art task force um seizes it
and the rhinox and the camel does never
see it again
it passes briefly through the hands of
hermann goering it's in his collection
for a while
he trades it for something else it
miraculously survives the war
and then in 1945 or 46 it's in this um
the famous show presided over by rose
vallon
the the woman who basically saved so
many of these jewish
owned artworks that were stolen um
in the tweelery gardens um where there's
a show put on basically for
any survivors to come and claim what
might
still be theirs if they're if they could
recognize it if they could make some
kind of claim and so
that painting is in the show the real
life iran can delve
who had sort of left the the community
of these families who had converted to
catholicism
who hid away in paris with her italian
passport
all throughout the war and who by all
intents and purposes never made any
effort to save her daughter in any way
despite her considerable resources which
is just horrible to
to read about but anyway um she sees the
painting in the show
she gets it back and you know keep in
mind it was a
it was a prized possession of her
daughter who had it in her living room
and her apartment in new year
um anyway iran the real life iran gets
the portrait back i mean it's an easy
claim to make because you know she could
say that this is
me you know when i was a little girl so
she gets it back and then
you know almost immediately she sells it
but the problem is who she sells it to
or whom she sells it to
and that is the um
arms dealer emile berla who
ran the i'm going to mispronounce with
the or clyon
arms factory in zurich during the war
and
you know this is a guy who collaborated
openly
with the nazis i mean he would say were
he here to defend himself but he also
provided arms to the allies but the
truth is
he made his fortune in selling arms and
war material to the nazis
and you know he often was in paris
during the war buying art
dubiously on the black market he bought
tons of stuff that belonged to
the rosenberg family the great family of
dealers
he was forced to give all that back and
the uh luckily paul rosenberg was still
around and after the war got a lot of it
back
but so iran the real-life errands sells
legally her her daughter's painting to
this man
and so today the painting remains
legally
in the collection of a former nazi
collaborator and there is no restitution
claim that can be made because
it was sold legally and it's it was sold
by the descendant
to this man and so the the painting
uh which is in a way one of the only
things that remains of bear truth to
kamundo
is kind of in this eternal captivity in
a way and it's just
it's quite awful to think about it i
don't know it really bothers me a lot
wow yeah and it's such a kind of an
incredible ending
uh uh to your book so
um very interesting question from
someone about
um whether this story of
jewish collectors how french is this
story um so is that are there were there
major jewish collectors in other
countries too
in britain germany
you know italy u.s even absolutely
um it's not a distinctly french story i
think
um well even that's complicated to say
because i mean i think
as you go from country to country the
styles of what was collected
and you know the the nature of the
collections change
um i think given that we are in france
and that there is this um distinctly
kind of french historical image that's
on display
um that is what is distinctly french
about this story
um although of course there were
examples of of others who collected this
kind of onstage regime style in in new
york and london at the time
right and so many of the french um you
know
collectors and dealers in impressionist
art were also jews so you know it's not
to say the jews were only collecting
right i was going to say and then the
other thing is that in so many other
cases especially elsewhere in europe
um there is this sort of very
deep relationship between jews and
modernism
and um and that's also very much the
case in in the us
for sure um sort of in new york and that
that time around the war
so it's difficult to say but i mean i
focused on people who were not doing the
sort of the avant-garde and the cutting
edge
um and you know at that time you know a
lot of other french
collectors had begun to collect um sort
of more
avant-garde uh more modernist pieces
because of various reasons but
i i um i was struck by
the kind of uniformity of this
one particular kind of social network
that is as i mentioned
all connected and all related and the
commonalities between what they were
buying and what they were donating and
what that meant
as a kind of collective statement so no
it's not unique to france in that sense
but i think it bears
a special significance because it was
there in that particular moment
yeah i thought um someone asked in in
the questions
um about the edmund de waal
um book and he just came out with a new
book on the camel dose which i
i just reviewed so i just have that very
fresh in my mind and it's interesting to
compare
um you guys have complementary but
slightly different interpretations
of some of these things so like that and
that's an example
i think so he reads the camondo
um uh obsession with the 18th century
as a nod to the kind of um
age of civility and enlightenment that
emancipated the jews
in a sense and you you i think do a very
interesting
reading of it which i found very
convincing as a kind of conservative
gesture
in terms of public friends yeah i think
that's right i mean i
again i mean uh the readers can can
judge um
what can we judge they think but i mean
i think that it's difficult to say
that it was a nod to the age that
um emancipated the jews because it's a
style that in fact predates
the emancipation of the jews in france
and so
you know that happened after the french
revolution
during the french revolution and the
style that these guys are hearkening
back to
is the sort of um nobility on the brink
um before all of that began so i i don't
really see the connection there
now another i was going to say another
kind of interesting divergence
or convergence maybe of interpretation
is
in you both discuss moise de comondo's
obsession with eliminating dust in his
museum
and um which you know he left these like
very detailed instructions for having
crazy instructions
are really crazy yeah and so i you know
so
dewall reads that as a kind of effort to
eliminate the traces of his jewish past
kind of so like dust is the the residue
from the past words you give i think a
very fascinating
reading of it as kind of trying to
cleanse the reputation
in a sense of of you know these families
you know that they were they were
involved in this sort of scandal
the different financial scandal shortly
before and stuff like that
yeah sure i mean that's a tough one i
mean i think
um i mean it is true that a lot of these
families
donated their i mean well one thing that
um i try to mention a little bit in the
book
is the the issue of the question of
judaica collections
um and how that um does and does not
intersect with these other collections
he's got rid of his father's judaica
collection well well i would say
he did but he didn't dispose of it he
donated it to
either the the the synagogue the
sephardic synagogue in the rubufo
um where it was to be used in the in the
temple and where some of it still is
and then also like the rothschilds he
donated a lot of the other pieces he had
to the musee de clooney where it was
also on display
so it's not as if and and display i
should mention under the name
kemundo so it's not as if the public is
not to see that the kamundos were a
jewish family
it's just that it did not necessarily
adhere to his totalizing vision
for this crazy versailles fantasy that
he was enacting
in the utmost where he lives i mean
that's my read on it i mean i think
look um louise dicamondo was not
uh was certainly not um in the business
of denying his jewishness
um he literally sued his ex-wife for
custody of their daughter because
she converted to catholicism and he did
not trust her
to be around a child who i mean i mean
it really
um i think there's a lot there and he
you know for instance
he was outraged that his son started
dating this woman during the first world
war who was not jewish
he was very invested in maintaining the
communal ties i think
i mean also the the given the
kind of invective of anti-semitism that
i mentioned i mean the name
kamundo was known to readers of
newspapers as a sort of foreign jewish
name
and he did not change the name of the
museum it's the musee
nissim de kamondo i mean it's not the
musee des articulative
which you know or whatever else it's it
is named after his son
because i think it's meant to show that
this immigrant family
is as proud of french as proud of france
as anyone else and it as
equally able to understand its genius so
i don't know that's my right i think
that that's one of the the things i
loved about
your book is you really give such a
nuanced
understanding of french jewish identity
you know so
you could look at these people and on
the surface and it's true that some of
them
convert like beatrice
but what you really show is that you
know what might
seem like a kind of disaffection from
judaism
um is really just uh you know that there
were different ways
of expressing those affiliations and yes
they change over the course of the 19th
century they become less traditional but
it's not a rejection of it i mean it's
like another way of being just another
way of being jewish
yeah um and through this question i i
just thought you that was just
very very beautifully done so last
question
and you know that someone uh pose and
which i think your book really
raises is you know what the um
this lesson has to tell us about um
anti-semitism
now in france i mean you are you know
you've been living in france for a while
you've been experiencing i know
um or you know writing about uh the rise
in anti-semitism so
what does your book have to tell us how
does it help us understand the situation
um
you know that is such a good and
complicated
question um you know i'm not i'm not
really sure i thought a lot about this
my i don't really know what the answer
is i mean on the one hand
i think you know just just very briefly
um
anti-semitism today is vastly different
than anti-semitism then
it has a whole other kind of discourse
and narrative
it has different origins and different
history to it i mean it really is
different i mean now
it is i mean it's again it's the words
are so important in this so let me let
me try to
um summarize it succinctly but
essentially
you know the the majority of
anti-semitic violence that we see in
france today
is perpetrated by um
uh authors with a similar cultural
background and that is often
uh kind of third generation immigrants
from uh france's former colonies in
north africa or west africa and so
that is a vastly different i mean of
course i should say you know there is
the
the lingering specter of the national
front and the sort of its roots and
holocaust denial
um but the the violent attacks that we
see
come from a kind of a different source
today
and you know i'm not sure that it is the
same story
um or that there really is a lesson to
be drawn
um and it's it's it's tricky because of
course you know you want to feel like
your work will explain kind of current
events but i'm not sure that mine really
does
in that sense i mean i i think um one
question
that is somewhat that that is the same
and like
that maury is of course the best person
here to
explain and to talk more about but is
the relationship
of particular minority communities to
french universalism
and maury has written about that so well
in the right to difference his book
about french universalism and the jews
and that i think is a real question
for french jews but especially for
french muslims these days
and i think that um if if there is any
parallel it's more in that
direction than it is in terms of like
the actual proximate factors that cause
anti-semitic violence in france today
yeah that's that's a great answer to
that question so
um a few people have asked whether this
is going to be recorded and the answer
is yes and it'll be
available um soon on the yipsa
ypsa website so we encourage you to tell
people about it
and please join me in um thanking
jake for this really enlight beautiful
uh
talk today and for the great book which
i encourage you all to read so
thank you all so much for having me yale
university press discount
yes okay thank you all
well thank you so much